Yeah right
good evening members in our visitors
tonight welcome to the Development
Committee on the 23rd of January 2020
our usual emergency evacuation
announcement should be.we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building via the nearest
available exit to the chamber our
assembly point will be in the public car
park at the side of the Civic suite
please don't delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please don't
return into the building until given
permission to do so by council staff
he's also note that the meeting will be
audio recorded and can I please remind
you to turn your mobile phones off or to
silent item one is apologies for absence
not confirm it's likely that councilor
Weston is not going to make it at this
moment in time we have no substitute
members attending but are non-members
counselor row councillor Dre councillor
Lumley counts the world concern council
sparing cancer step toe counselor mr.
hora cancel mrs. Howe as the mrs. Mason
okay thank you
minutes of the meeting held on 19th of
December 2019 we'd be happy for me to
sign those as a correct and accurate
record of that meeting thank you very
much
item 5 is our declarations of interest
now it's a step toe take German with
regard to items 7 & 8 just to record
that I am also the county councillor for
that area that's mr. Stroh
Thank You chairman item six and by
virtue of being a member of Rayleigh
Town Council however I did not attend
the council meeting when this was item
was discussed thank you right item six
well mr. chairman as member of Rayleigh
Town Council and again I'm not a member
of that planning committee okay thank
you
cats purring I'm so lovely
okay just in the nick of time here all
right okay let's get started then on the
council Stanley sorry mister there okay
members can you remember to use your
microphone because with the aircon
buzzing away sounds not carrying quite
as it normally does
so item six land to the rear of ninety
eight to one to eight
High Street Rayleigh and just reminders
I've already mentioned counts the canal
that's Reeves you've got seen the
addendum okay thank you thank you
chairman this is an application for a
mixed-use development containing
thirty-five flats and two commercial
units on the screen is the location plan
and you'll see that the sites in a
regular shape to the rear of properties
on the high street and railing the site
is within partly within um the
conservation area access is proposed
between numbers of one one zero and 106
High Street close to the roundabout
junction with Eastwood road immediately
bordering the site are a mix of
commercial units along the high street
at ground-floor and some of these units
contain commercial uses above as well so
to take you through these two units here
are entirely commercial you then get to
an a commercial unit at the ground floor
here with some fairly recent refused a
residential unit that the first floor in
this unit along here we have residential
units above the ground floor commercial
units and this row of properties here
has residential at first and second
floor this is then the library that
adjoins part of the joins were Jason to
the western boundary and then this part
here is the playground to Raley primary
school which is again to the west this
is the grass playing area for the school
as well then along this part of the
northern boundary you've got a residue
property number seven a crown Hill with
its residential curtilage and you've got
another residential property to Crown
Hill adjacent to this corner of the site
to the walk to the eastern boundary is a
car parking area set on a slightly lower
land level and again these properties
here are commercial sorry this area here
is a residential at first floor you've
got one single story building you've got
a residential flat above the
ground-floor commercial use here and
this here is a ground-floor retail unit
with a gym use above so there are a
mixture of existing uses surrounding
this site if we can take you to the
aerial image this will show you some of
the contacts although it's a bit dark to
see but this is the access here through
there between the two commercial
buildings either side and then you go in
to what was the these are shows the
buildings at the dairy crest site this
is a mixture of buildings on there this
is the flat roof of the library adjacent
and the proposal seeks to demolish all
of the existing buildings but retaining
the existing retaining wall that goes
around the outside this is the
playground to the adjoining school and
you can see the grassed school field
this is that neighboring commercial
property here sorry residential property
number seven a crown Hill and then you
can see the adjacent car park to the
eastern boundary if I can take you to
the proposed site layout please so this
is the proposed site layout as you can
see vehicle access is using the existing
access onto the high street what would
happen and you can sort of see here is
that the access way sort of angles um to
this side so as you look at the site and
I'll show you some photos in a short
while there is an existing access point
into the site which is not in this
location this proposed access is shifted
slightly towards the east and it would
be in the position of one of the
buildings on the site that's going to be
demolished so if you keep that in mind
I'll explain
in more detail shortly so the virtual
access would come up the existing
slightly divert office an angle and then
there would be a central sorter
courtyard area with two disabled bays
and some landscaping for for use of the
flooded block the access would then go
underneath on the undercroft towards the
parking area that would be contained
towards the western boundary adjacent to
the library and then this is part of
that school playing yard and to the
north the building itself would be
u-shaped so this was the access point in
the middle at ground floor and it would
be a combination of one and to bed flats
to the ground floor and it's a
combination of one and to bed flats
across all floors provided the ground
floor flats would benefit from amenity
space towards the boundary so between
the sort of rear elevations and the
boundary on all sides and the first
floor flats would benefit from balconies
as would the second and this and the
story at the top of the building
integral refuse stores are proposed so
you've got one here to serve the
commercial building here and the
commercial unit on the other side would
have a refuse store here so the
commercial units re would be either side
of the development as you go up the
entrance and from the high street
there's a commercial vehicle space for
parking here and here either side of the
access there are also integral in stores
for the residential units so there's one
here and here and throughout the
building dotted around are some integral
cycle stores if I can take you to the
elevations please
might just take a moment to load
I'll speak while it's loading the
building would be for story with the
fourth story inset a long part of the
northern elevation so gate you've got
four storey building but this part is
inset and that will show you more
carefully that on the floor plans when
we get to those so that doesn't extend
across the entire all the other stories
on the building and you'll see that part
of the building is two storey adjacent
to the northern boundary so this image
at the top is what you would see as you
enter the site and there would be a
parking space here and here either side
to serve the commercial units at the
ground floor the form of the building
would be flat roofed with a modern
arrangement of fenestration and
balconies provided to all floors above
ground level for them to take you to the
what we've got is some 3d images to show
you the proposed development in its
context so this is as you look down the
existing access so what you'd see at
ground floor level is one of the
commercial units there this image would
have a parking lot there would be a
parking space for the commercial unit
just here and then you've got the
balconies to the residential
accommodation above this you can see in
the background is a two-story element
that would be set back towards the
northern boundary you can take you to
the next if you scroll down on that
image I'll yeah so we then get a wider
view
so back down East Wood Road looking
towards the site what you have is you
can see the fourth storey which will be
formed of a different facing material to
give a bit of contrast to the brickwork
that will be used on the other floors we
can take you to the last one perhaps
and again that that will show you the
same part of the fourth floor there but
you just get a glimpse of the retail
unit with the flats above that would be
glimpsed obliquely on this front looking
from Eastwood Road in a sort of
northwesterly direction I could take you
through the photos please yep so this is
the this is an image of the existing
access and the part of the access up to
this point sorry if we can go back to
the last one so part of the existing
access is an adopted access by the
County Council to the High Street up to
this point here where it becomes a
private drive and you'll see at the
moment there is a foot way alongside
here but some sort of ad hoc parking
does happen along here this is the
adjoining retail unit or ground floor
with the gym above take you to the next
one so this is again showing the
commercial premises so this is entirely
commercial just to give you a context of
the surrounding uses adjacent through
the access the next one please
so this is now within the site looking
back down the access towards the high
street and you've got this is the point
at which the existing driveway veers
towards the eastern boundary this is all
in sort of commercial use with the gym
above there's no residential use
bordering the site in that location I
can take you to the next one this is a
wider context so than existing parking
area for premises to the rear here next
one sorry Katie thank you so this shows
you some of the residential uses that
border the site towards the south so
this is the frontage of this building
would be onto the high street and these
are in residential use this part of the
building and that's adjacent to the
library building which is here this is
the existing foundry fencing to the site
so this would go in the proposal and
what you'd have is the commercial unit
at ground-floor quite close to this
boundary with some new fenestration
in this location here next one please
Katie thank you so this is one of the
buildings within the site and which
would be demolished as part of the
proposal and they exist the proposed
access point or the existing access is
approximately here and the proposed one
would be sort of part way along this
building so the building would go a new
access point would be part way along
here these two spaces here could be
retained for use for parking within the
proposed layout and then this is the
part of the private drive access way
which veers off to the east and boundary
and so this is part of the building on
the site that would be demolished as
part of the proposal and what you'd have
here adjacent to this boundary is the
other commercial unit and then this is
the eastern boundary and so this no
change is proposed to this boundary
treatment here and beyond that boundary
is an area of parking this is some
existing parking for one of the adjacent
units the coop Funeral Care and again
that's adjacent to the eastern boundary
so these are the buildings within the
site so this is what it looks like at
the moment it's been vacant for some
time and so there's no existing
commercial use and all of this would be
demolished as part of the proposal I
think there's one further image which is
of looking west so this is the wall
which will be retained and that's the
library building to part of that
boundary if take you back to the
proposed site plan then just to explain
that the proposed use is for 35 flats to
commercial units and this use is
considered to record with your raelia
Tralee center area action plan this
identifies this vacant site as one for
mixed-use including residential the
proposal would help to support the
vitality and viability of the town
center whilst the principle of the
proposed use is accepted detailed
considerations are also of importance
and have been considered in the officer
report I'll just take you through some
impacts in relation to residential
amenity by looking at the
floorplan so in terms of the ground
floor were not concerned about any
potential for overlooking given that the
existing boundary wall would be retained
as approximately two meters high this is
the first floor and if we look at this
firstly this boundary to this side you
can see there are a number of balconies
and a number of windows serving bedrooms
and living spaces and kitchens towards
this boundary this boundary is
immediately adjacent to the playground
for Rayleigh primary school and then
this corner of the site looking
northwards is immediately adjacent to
part of the playing field for that
school the northern boundary here then
runs alongside in quite close proximity
to the rear garden of number-7 a crown
Hill and the proposal does seek to
include a number of windows to various
parts of the flatted the flats so you've
got bedrooms lounges and you've got
balconies towards the east and side
there is a condition number five which
we would just seek to update to require
the Mosuo glazing to the windows at
first floor here and then again at
second floor because you'll see on the
second floor plan and the proposal does
include similar fenestration here which
would be immediately adjacent to the
rear bound the rear boundary and the
rear elevation of that dwelling it's not
shown but the rear of the dwelling is
approximately where my life might be and
then they've got a rear amenity space
behind their property so those would be
obscure glacé prevent any ability for
direct overlooking there i've said above
second floor level so in the center of
the site
there's no fenestration proposed because
this part is two-story only and then if
you take you to the next one please
Katie so this shows the final so the top
floor is building with this bits quite
inset from the northern boundary so
given the separation there there's not
concern relating to these windows that
would be to these flats here there are
fenestration at 1st 2nd and 3rd floor in
both of these elevations including
balconies
but the residential uses I mentioned
previously that are above the existing
commercial uses on the high street also
a sufficient distance between them to
guard against any unreasonable level of
overlooking if I can take you to the
proposed site plan again just to point
out that there are 21 parking spaces
proposed so the majority here but a
couple here and then one for each
commercial use there so one space for
each of the commercial units 19 spaces
for the flats and there's a combination
of one and two-bed flats so some of the
flats would have no parking
given the high street location the
recommendation is that this is
acceptable given that there's a mixture
of other transport uses within walking
distance 35 cycle spaces are proposed
which is in line with the parking
standard so in terms of the access here
the access point to the site would
divert slightly or off it would still
allow for two cars to park in this area
that's outside the sort of application
site as it were what we have is a late
consultation response from the council
street scene team in relation talk to
vehicle tracking for the refuse cart so
what they inform us and what we have
observed from the photos shown is that
some parking does happen in this
location here
the tracking diagram that the applicant
has provided it shows the refuse truck
coming into the site reversing down here
and sorry coming in and then having the
ability to turn to go out of the site
again in forward gear what that would be
prohibited if there was a dog barking
along this turning head so as part of
the proposal we are seeking the
applicant enter into a section 106
agreement so we can control have a
scheme of parking management to control
this area here to ensure that that
refuse vehicle can turn safely and exit
then in forward gear in terms of
contributions while sites that this size
would usually be required to provide
affordable housing on
this is subject to viability an
appraisal has been submitted and
independently tested and the conclusion
reached that no contribution could be
made by this site the recommendation
chairman is therefore one of approval
subject to the recommended conditions
with the addition of a change to one of
the conditions to update a revised
location plan and a slight change to
condition five to require the OBS
glazing in relation to the first and
second floor in relation to the flat
mentioned in that condition already with
the addition of a section 106 for a
parking management strategy to enable
refuse collection for the site and
turning thank you thank you we have
three speakers on this item
that's the mercer last Town Council up
to five minutes
Thank You chairman councillors good
evening I'm councillor Deborah mercer
chairman of rail etang Council pending
in highways committee and I'm here
tonight to convey the committee's
objection to the application of the old
Derek West site we are aware that these
sites has been vacant since 2014 and
know that there is a need for
redevelopment what we would like to see
though is the right development one that
is in keeping with their precious
conservation area and not just an MPhil
of as many dwellings as deem possible
the thirty-five flats fourteen
one-bedroom in 21 two bedroom together
with the two token commercial units our
purpose behind the high street up a
fairly fairly narrow exit road which
usually has cars parked alongside this
road is the axis for other commercial
residents or units and there has been
comment that the funeral home has said
he she issued in the past with
manoeuvrability due to these parked cars
there is no lighting with none proposed
and he's presently dark and secluded at
night there was also no pavement
proposed along the access road
potentially creating a hazard for
pedestrians especially if one vehicle
wants to go in and one out and/or with
cars that are parked on one side as well
the access road attaches to the high
streets at an extremely busy and almost
permanently congested junction with a
mini roundabouts and pedestrian
crossings vehicles wanting to access it
by turning right will cause even more
congestion than at present and vehicles
wanted to exit the road and termites
will need to stop traffic coming from
the Rayleigh wheel this contemporary an
industrial looking flat roof development
is up to four storeys high built with
light colored brick grey metal cladding
and bronze windows and doors and
completely out of keeping with it being
within the Rayleigh conservation area it
is highly visible from behind the
surrounding properties Dwarfs the
single-story Eden independent financial
advisers and he's overbearing dominant
imposing and detrimental to the local
in history at the top of Crown Hill
being in full view to the grades who
listed buildings the Dutch cottage and
the crown public house the photo which
was not shown on the slide show but
actually is in the planning application
the west of the Development Board rest
of the Development Board is the Rayleigh
primary school playground and playing
field and could have a safeguarding
issue with overlooking primary school
children there have only been twenty-one
minimum parking standard spaces provided
for the flats two of which are for
disabled parking parking standard
stipulates 56 bases plus nine for
visitors that's forty four spaces short
they have also only provided two parking
spaces for the commercial units less
than half the required amount there is
no affordable housing offered if we use
the 35 percent rule then twelve units
should be affordable but the viability
statement has indicated that this is not
viable and this is not acceptable as it
feels that some should be offered we are
concerned that there will be issues with
construction traffic blocking the access
for the existing units and impacting on
the congestion at this part of the high
street before that this using him in
appropriate development for the site out
of character in a conservation area is
overdevelopment and should be rejected
by this committee thank you thank you
mister friend
in five minutes I'll let you know when
you've got a minute to go
okay thank you okay I'm clean from open
architecture so thank you for the
opportunity to speak and support to be
application for the former Derrick rest
site and thank you for taking the time
to visit the site on Saturday the 18th
and following of the your meeting we're
trying to address some of the comments
and questions that were raised we feel
that a scheme offers a great opportunity
to provide much-needed housing on a
disused redundant and derelict site just
off of the high street providing
much-needed one and two-bedroom
properties in the area within a stone's
throw of a time Center while still
providing an employment opportunity on
the site in a former - number of
commercial units referencing the
existing architectural materials of site
we've progressed a scheme in
consultation of roxor District Council
and Essex County Council the proposals
that have been put forward to you today
in regards to the items that we'll
discuss
obviously the refuse truck and delivery
trucks it was only today but we'd had it
noted with them obviously the Town
Council own team had reviewed that
however when our team reviewed it and it
was checked by six County Council the
track improved and the calculations
proved that this was possible with the
introduction of a parking management
plan this would still be the case in
terms of intent terms of the pedestrian
footways it's my clients intention to
lase with all interested parties to
redevelop and resurface the access road
and courtyard directly outside the
proposed site as this area at the moment
is not in within his ownership the
intent is to greatly improve the
landscaping and do this all in one
material such as block pave years or
similar for both vehicle and pedestrian
routes creating a shared surface in line
with the recommendations contained
within the manual for streets the nature
of a space will naturally encourage
slower vehicle movements create an
environment which pedestrians walk
without feeling and intimidated by motor
traffic
promotes social interaction and creates
safer environments for all users in
connection with this the parking for all
users of this area will be formalized
and agreed to ensure all accommodated
and parking the vehicles in a unapproved
or unsatisfactory areas does not occur
in addressing this area and part of a
landscaping proposal that would be
submitted under condition would also
look to ensure this area we well
illuminated in accordance was secured by
design Stan
as a minimum in regards to be overlooked
in we consider the development will
create any overlooking issues to
adjacent properties over school boundary
between the school and pros will seek to
retain an existing brick work for which
in this locations is around three to
three and a half meters the proposed
building has been set back from the
boundary and kept to only three storeys
in height to the north and east corners
with the section of building between
these corners only be in two-story added
to this is considered due to the times
of operation for the school and a usual
working day the homes will largely be
vacant during school hours it has been
provisionally agreed with watcher
District Council but windows to a flank
elevation of units 5 & 6 as noted by
Katie would be obscured to any potential
overlooking from these properties into
the adjacent residential property all
other rooms face away from this actual
property in terms of a boundary
treatment in terms of the boundary to
the existing area or a large proportion
of a site the Southwest Northwest and
northeast boundaries of site would
retain the existing two three and three
and a half metre Wars these are in good
condition and will continue to provide
good separation between our client site
and adjoining owners sites this will
help with privacy and security where
needed and avoid disruptions of a joint
known as if I were to be removed and
replaced the south eastern boundary
around the car park areas and intended
to be enclosed with a steel railings
painted black
this will provide right level of
security whilst allowing views into the
carpark from outside and also Heights
onto the adjoining land helping with
self surveillance and security it is
intended to the landscape inside of the
railings with low level evergreen
hedging and other soft landscaping
division enhance the public realm of the
site into can crease the flora and fauna
the site increasing biodiversity the
remaining boundary is obviously made up
of the commercial units in guards to the
car parking in an area where climate
changes at the forefront we have a
responsibility where we can to try and
reduce reliance and use of the private
craft we've worked closely with watcher
District Council and Essex
Kancil Prewitt fruit pre-application
advice and during development of the
application see today we've been
actively encouraged to reduce the amount
of car parking spaces on the site and
this is justified by its time center
location the site is located just off of
a high street where local shops and
services can be found the site is within
walking distance of the train station
and numerous bus routes with stops on
the high street or nearby roads the site
is also within distance of nearby
schools public parks and various leisure
facilities the reliance on a car when
living in this development would be
greatly reduced this would be perfect
for young or old alike where the cost of
owning a car can be prohibitive it would
still like to earn their own home
final speak on this item mr. brown
you ready in five minutes okay yeah okay
hi I'm Russell Brown I'm the residence a
small field place which is also called
7a I'm going to talk about the effect
this development will have on the
property I live in and first of all and
then I'm gonna address the inaccuracies
that have been presented and finally I'm
gonna speak about some of the planning
policies which there's proposal fails to
adhere to first of all the proposed
building is too close to my home it's
roughly parallel with the rear of my
property and at its closest it's 12
meters away
the Essex design guide says that it's
much too close it says there should be a
minimum of 25 meters between the
properties the guide goes on to say that
when a new development backs on to the
rear of existing housing the new
development shouldn't be closer than 15
meters from the existing boundary some
parts of this new development are
directly next to my boundary wall next
three units in the proposed building
would have windows which looked directly
into my house the dwellings would
overlook two bedrooms my kitchen and my
lounge the design guide says the upper
storey living rooms of the new
development should be no closer than 35
meters away instead the closest of these
rooms is 16 meters away several of the
other proposed dwellings were look into
the gardens of my property which are not
currently overlooked third the new
building will cause a significant loss
of light it should be noted that the
land on my side of the wall is lower
than the land on the dairy side my house
is two stories high and it's built on a
level lower than the dairy the proposed
design places two and three storey
elements next to my southern boundary
the three-story part is about 10 metres
high which is nearly too taut I'm sorry
nearly three times as high as the
current wall that wall already cuts out
like to the back garden until about
10:00 a.m. in winter so a building three
times as high is going to significantly
reduce the amount of sunlight reaching
my home as you can see the proposed
building is situated much too close to
my home it blocks out the light and
produces unacceptable overlooking next I
wanted to address some of the
inaccuracies presented in documents
submitted to the committee some of those
have been corrected today but
I'm going to go through them anyway the
boundary between the properties is not
tree-lined there's three rather sparse
holy trees along a wall which is about
45 minutes long the proposed building is
presented as being only two storeys tall
next to my southern boundary but that
isn't true
both two and three story elements are
directly next to the boundary wall the
documents claim that overlooking issues
have been eliminated they have not the
highest of the proposed dwellings would
have its windows obscured but the units
on the first floor will still be able to
see over the wall and into my house the
dairy is estimated to have produced 58
vehicle trips a day and it is therefore
claimed that the new development will be
unlikely to create traffic problems
however most of the journeys from the
dairy would have been carried out by
electric milk floats early in the
morning assuming not all over the 35 new
dwellings are occupied by milk men many
of the vehicle trips generated by the
new building can be expected to be
during rush hour
adding to the congestion and air
pollution already experienced in Riley
finally the officer's report says that
the site is not in the air quality
management area that's not the case it
is in the zone this is because part of
the site is within the area and it's
made clear by the air quality management
order that if any part of the property
is within the zone all of it is the core
strategy says that to protect the health
of people living there
no resent residential development should
be allowed within the air quality
management area this brings me to my
final points which that's several
aspects of the proposed building fail to
adhere to planning policies there's not
enough parking there's no affordable
homes there's not enough play space
there's not enough outside area for the
ground floor flats part of this site is
in the Rayleigh conservation area
therefore much of the designs
inappropriate according to the design
guide guidelines for conservation areas
for example the proposed design is too
big is too tall it uses non-traditional
materials and window patterns it has a
flat roof and employs a solider course
thank you the design doesn't reflect the
character of the area nor at four
storeys does it match the scale the
Conservation Area action plan praises
the dari has been good use of a
background sight but building a
four-story block of main
Flass will represent a massive change in
terms of character fusing to the site
was very different as we've seen the the
visuals show that the building will be
visible above other existing buildings
from the town center the change in use
will also represent the loss of
potential for this site it is a large
area which could be used for leisure
commercial or community facilities uses
which are supported by the Riley center
area action plan I understand the plans
are able to have looked certain policies
when appropriate but should all of these
policy breaches be overlooked it's for
these reasons the loss of light the loss
of privacy the failure to adhere to many
planning policies and guidelines that I
think the proposal should be rejected
thank you for listening to me I was
expecting to see Forrester hands right
okay counselor oh well like to make a
start actually Chairman I think of
common courtesy I would like to see the
ward councillor speak first I can come
back in after that because you just take
your microphone a bit closer please
Thank You mr. chairman I agree with many
of the comments of those who have spoken
against this proposal this evening and
what I've heard and seen it is in my
opinion that opposed it was clearly out
of character and overbearing being in
part on three storeys I agree that the
previous speaker that despite the
provision of screening they would remain
the potential to overlook nearby
residential properties and in particular
a school playground and playing field
based on the proposal prose number of
units a thirty-five parking in my
opinion at twenty four twenty one spaces
in is an it is inadequate both in number
and size
the entrance to the site via the high
street appears it inadequate and this
would again in my opinion add to the
already congested town center traffic
particularly mr. chairman at rush hour
the site if it is not a in in it is
adjacent to the present air quality
management area and I am would in my
opinion have a detrimental effect on the
current area input in increasing
pollution
for these reasons a stated mr. Chairman
I urge the committee to refuse his
application as it has been presented
that's the world concern Thank You
chairman it's becoming it's becoming a
disturbingly regular practice
unfortunately for ward councillors to
have to attend development committees in
order to defend the rights of the
residents against what we perceived to
be inappropriate planning applications
and it deeply saddens me that yet again
and only one month after the application
for the open development 241 crown Hill
in Raley here we are again with yet
another over development of a site
within my ward in Raley Center a Lee
this application is to develop a site
within the center of Raley town center
of site which is currently derelict and
I'm personally in favor of an
appropriate development of this site
design with any other site in our
district which is currently lying empty
there's applications for 35 black sand
to commercial premises the officers
report on which the recommendations were
proven is recorded comes with a variety
conditions on which I agree and support
however there are so many issues with
this application that I know some of my
colleagues is next we're going to take
issue with some of them so I'm going to
touch on a number of them the one I want
to talk about what the first one I want
to talk about chairman is these parking
which was already been touched on but it
needs to be expanded on a site with 35
flats only allowing 19 parking spaces
well that leaves 17 flats without a
parking space for their vehicles so does
the planning officer and do the does the
developer really expect that they will
only sell the 17 flats without parking
spaces to people who do not own a car
and agree never to own one of course
they don't
so the reality is that every flat will
have at least one vehicle attached to it
so where does the developer expect those
17 people to park and Webster's way and
pay every day well of course not they
won't do that
so in recommending this for approval I
cannot help the feeling that the
Planning Department has totally ignored
the impact on the town that 17 flat
owners without suitable parking will
have and with vehicles being abandoned
we've already seen Raley is not Southend
Southend as a Metropolitan town where
high-rise flats are now becoming the
norm in the street scene Raley is a
market town within the London commuter
belt and I for one did not want to see
it changed because developers are
allowed to routinely change the street
scene and I'm sure that residents will
agree with this according to the parking
standards policy which was adopted by
full council in December 2010 and I'd
like to add at this point that it was
not so long ago that a developer tried
to suggest that this policy was adopted
so long ago that it should hold little
weight but a planning aspect to
adjudicators appeal overruled them and
stood by the planning Department's
decision and so in their eyes as policy
still holds a lot awaitin and I can see
taking note Katie that was 18 /z
reserved for double nine which was on
the recent members bulletin according to
this policy this development should have
the following spaces provided for it
56 bases for residents nine spaces for
visitors was a total of 65 spaces this
proposal provides 19 which is 46 fewer
or in other words it's less than a third
or what it should be providing and in
addition the spaces which should be 5
meters by 2.9 meters and size are not
they're 5 meters by 2.5 meters in size
it is becoming normal now to read an
officer reports the minimum parking
space required is 5 meters by 2.5 that
is incorrect a parking bay of that size
can only be permitted in exceptional
circumstances the minimum space is 5
meters by 2.9 meters and less
exceptional circumstances can be shown
to exist and I understand that there can
be relaxation of the policy but I would
question whether this is relaxation of
the policy or completely ignoring the
policy and I'd like to pick up on one
point which was made June and the of the
officers presentation regarding section
106 the section 106 parking space they
my understanding is that the spaces at
the back of those units are chimera
commercially owned there are a number of
premises there there are a number of
complaints currently on the planning
portal from nearby premises and I've
visited these businesses and spoken to
the staff namely co-op Funeral Care and
Eden independent financial advisors no
connection I understand with the
developer both of these companies have
parking to the rear the funeral business
needs constant access for its vehicles
they have had problems with people have
annoyed the parking their bays innit
legal and illegal parking from clients
of the gym upstairs and the owner of the
gym allegedly has tries to buy the
spaces but has failed because he needs
them the lack of suitable parking this
development would exacerbate the issue
and I questioned therefore how that
section 106 agreement would work because
from what was being described on there
my understanding is that's where the
current parking spaces are for those two
companies the entrance road is as pinch
points and everyday vehicles are parked
on the curve even if we take a pragmatic
view about this development and say the
very least the developer should provide
is one space for flat plus parking that
would equate to any thirteen flats
that's 13 and not 35 and that's with
just one space per flat which is not a
policy requires policy requires two four
four four some of them German if that's
not evidence of a massive over
development of this site then I'll be
really glad if someone could point asked
me what is in addition I just quickly
like to take issue with two other points
it's already been touched on their
quality as has been quite rightly said
this development is partly within the
Raley Air Quality Management Area
certainly the entrance the only entrance
to this site is and it therefore should
conform with county with council policy
env v which it doesn't I also have an
issue with a lack of infrastructure
contribution of the development the
officer reports sites profit margins
amongst the reasons for acceptable
Planning Department for its to accept
they're accepting this however this
developer is in business and in business
you should take a full informed decision
rather than taking a punt the developer
should have known that there is a
requirement for them if they are
constructing 35 flats to make a
financial contribution to infrastructure
along with affordable housing and the
other issues that are being
if having worked out the maths resulting
from the purchase price of the plot the
construction cost perspective sales
prices contributions and everything else
they can't make their usual usual profit
margin but then that that's they look at
with respect and I can't see what that's
got to do with us it's not for us to be
bailing out developers German I agree
this site needs to be developed
I agree but yet again this is an example
in my opinion of a greedy money focused
developer trying to squeeze as much out
of a plot of land as they can without
any regard for the local residents or
planning policy and our planning
department are seeking that you approve
this are therefore implore you and your
committee please to refuse this
application on the grounds of over
developments and nonconformity with
planning policy thank you
Thank You chairman um I agree
wholeheartedly with everything that my
colleagues have said so I'm not going to
bore you with the same things again the
site clearly is dire and needs something
doing to it but as far as I'm concerned
it's over development and then allowing
the access issues a question for Katy
please it's not a to improvi
sorry could I do make you statements
okay miss peecher's we were advised then
on Saturday at the site visit that some
questions were no we're gonna be asked
of Essex County Council and we would be
sorry County highways and we would be
given an addendum for tonight's meeting
I for one have not received an addendum
I'm not sure if my colleagues have um
but well basically are there answers to
the questions or not thank you that's
mr. hoi Thank You chairman it's not our
evil counselors who are turning up
tonight because of their application its
councillors from there around the
district because we are all unhappy
around around the way our policy is
being ignored first thing tomorrow
morning I will be writing to our ad for
place and environment I think it is mr.
cotton and I'll be also writing to our
planning manager asking why we actively
encouraged a reduction in
parking spaces beyond their policy as
stated by the agent earlier in this
meeting I'll be checking the recording
to make sure other words but that values
were the words used actively encouraged
and I want to know why we are actively
encouraging people not to abide by our
policies moving on from there
parkland has already been mentioned
councillor Wilkinson has stolen my
thunder because I normally go on about
parking forever but you're lucky tonight
because I want to be he stated it very
well not only are they not there too few
spaces yet again we are going to the
so-called minimum space rather than the
preferred space the minimum size space
should be used exceptionally I believe
exception is abnormally why I don't know
it should be the preferred space another
statement in here says that we are
encouraging minimum space standards
because it wouldn't prove the
Landscaping's scheme which suggests
there's a problem of the landscaping as
well moving on from that to landscaping
or indoor amenity space and Joey it's
very unclear this report whether or not
there is sufficient amenity space there
isn't as far as I can tell it says it
there isn't enough amenity space
provided because of the ways it's
constructed it says that it could be
made up by the use of green space at the
front of the building block our briefs
our policy doesn't say there must be a
meaty space of 25 square meters per and
flat on average it says usable amenity
space which doesn't mean that a cup of
trees at the front of the building so
clearly it does not comply with our
amenity space standard either it says
it's close to st. George's Park is it
close I mean a MIDI space is generally
used by young people children but maybe
by adults but young children would have
to cross to Main Roads busy roads to get
to San George's Park and there and it
must be a quarter of a mile away
third of a mile away at least interested
Georgie's Park it's not close and that's
a ridiculous statement to make
moving on submit further ridiculous
statements to make regarding the parking
sorry I'm going to be around of it it
says it is also adjacent to the council
Road public car park when it talks about
parking and Webster's wake up or
unclothed ellipsis wake up okay I'll get
my dictionary out to adjoining a Jason
is adjoining
or next to the Ethan it's across a main
road and through it a dark alley or door
or down the Beast Wood Road and Marxist
fences is it no sense adjacent to that
car parks okay in the report I find miss
leading then on to the size and bulk of
the building the the impressions are
from a High Street Eastwood Road area I
haven't seen any from the crown Hill
area from the station area from Love
Lane area where the or where this
building would dominate the skyline as
far as I can tell it he's significantly
higher than the buildings currently
they're the next base is just a couple
of vital it's really just one item which
is about conditions it is mentioned in
the reports on page four no paragraph
four point five and page six point two
six about secured for design I know the
agent again mentioned lighting within
the landscaping and mentioned also
secured by design but actually the
condition does not make you just
mentions landscaping there's no mention
of lighting as a condition and it's
clearly required vibe essex urban places
and by the police in there secured
design but we have air condition is
missing the lighting aspect of it
overall then i think this isn't one of
those developments which demonstrates
sorry it's it demonstrates over
development but by the fact that it's
not just a little bit out there's many
policies it's not not applying any and
by that it shows that he is over
development in the area also it's
contrary to our policy on parkland it's
contrary to our policy on amenity space
and also size and bulk and I think on
that basis the committee should consider
refusing this application thank you
cancer Steptoe you'd indicated Thank You
chairman I totally endorse what's been
said before so I won't waste time going
over all that again there's a couple of
bits that I would urge the committee to
follow up on and ask questions of the
officers in particularly around the 106
contributions there doesn't appear to be
anything significant with regards to
education health care and all roads just
as a minimum I'm very curious to
understand why where there is no social
housing affordable housing yes I'm fully
aware our policy does allow for
adjustment of the 35% to my knowledge
and I would ask the committee just to
verify this and I'm sure officers will
correct it if it's wrong to my knowledge
I don't think we have accepted any
planning applications with 0% I cannot
go to quote on one in Starline and Greg
Wakering where we agree to 10% unless
unless I there are others that I can't
remember so what is the justification
for 0% the other option of course with
that contribution is that it I think our
policy does say that you can offset that
by a contribution
towards development somewhere else
to my knowledge and I asked the
committee to confirm this to my
knowledge I don't believe we've ever
actually done that there may be one or
two but I'm I can't recall any of this
so German I would urge the committee at
this stage to really look at refusing
this application I suspect that the
applicant 'yes it's a speculative
application to see how far he can push
the envelope and I think he will leave
leave tonight realizing he can't push it
any further thank you thank you mrs.
Mason Thank You mr. chairman I can only
say that and ask that members of the
development committee that obviously are
going to hear this listened to the
wide-ranging concerns with members from
over the whole of the district this
isn't just railing you've got members
here speaking from east west and central
or just cover a couple of points that I
think is significant the access concerns
I think you need to look at the other
concern I have which I would ask members
to rise questions of is it would appear
that there's proposing management of
land that is not in the applicants
control and I don't see how we can have
a 106 agreement over land that is not in
the applicant site but I again would
lead leave you to determine that but
basically I can only endorse what's
being said this is gross over
development and a lack of 'dearest to
policies and I do hope that you will
support the ward councillors and other
members in considering refusal of this
application thank you do any other of
our non ma'am mrs. hooker sir mister
sorry about you've asked for 106 money
for the private land for the turning
yeah well you said 106 confucian yeah
just clarify that small element not find
that nor financial contribution in
relation to the turning head but
managing a so a system of managing
vehicle parking around that area because
good to start that one that won't be in
your control because it's a it's classed
as a private round so the second point
I'd like to raise is about the social
housing we have a policy of 35 same and
there's too many developers small
developers coming through now saying oh
we can't afford it
anyone can fill in paperwork but say
they can't afford coming so I the only
time you're going to know whether Dell
developer as major lost is when they
sold the properties and that's so I
think this should be refused on me on
the basis of the Affordable Health whole
affordable housing not being there and
then I'd like to point out yet again as
if County Council hasn't asked for any
money for education well as far as I
know
rady primary is full and trains full
bits is full so I mean it's yes again
Essex comes back and says they don't
need any money something and then my
last thing I want to point out about the
parking just to make it clear it's 44
spaces that the developer development is
short on
thank you very much okay
and just before I open it up to members
would you like to make some some
comments and particularly wouldn't mind
covering the highways issues the amenity
and section 106 and other general
improvements please yeah so taking us
it's County Council highways first I did
speak to them at length we discussed and
their view that there is an existing
access to this site there's an adopted
access to the point with the high street
as they see it this is an existing
access that served vehicle movements in
relation to the dairy crest site and
that the proposal would introduce
vehicle movements in relation to the
commercial and opposed dwellings but in
their view the application would not
have any greater impact in terms of the
operational highway because there's no
proposed change to the existing access
and here to the highway so they're not
creating any new access points onto the
highway so we're not looking at
visibility splays or anything like that
it's an existing access that could be
used again tomorrow in relation to that
use although although that is now
redundant that's how they see it they're
not going to change their mind so the
county council's view is still that they
raised no objection in relation to this
application what I might add is that I
spoke to them in relation to so not just
this concern but more widely sort of
this concern about is this access
suitable in relation to the movement of
vehicles and pedestrians on the basis
that you might take the view that this
proposal introduces more pedestrians
into this area than the dairy crest use
did you know you've got the occupants of
the flats alongside potential customers
and workers in these commercial units
that is a matter for the council to
decide on whether they think
this is appropriate to given this change
in proposal but the counter counts are
not going to change their mind their
view is still that the access doesn't
change and it's an existing access point
and therefore it will not impact on but
in any more significant way or adversity
in relation to the functioning
carriageway which is the high street
that's all I can say in relation to
Essex County Council highways response
in relation to education the
contributions that might normally be
expected from a site of this scale well
education we've consulted the County
Council and they we clarified with them
but because this doesn't meet their
threshold 50 dwellings they are not
interested in seeking a financial
contribution and there's nothing we can
do about that they have their own policy
but but there we are in relation to
healthcare it's much the same there's a
threshold at which the NHS commissioners
want to look at sites and seek
contributions and they adopt a similar
approach to the county council in
relation to education and there's
nothing we can do in relation to that
apart from keep raising our concern that
they're not seeking such contributions
even relation to smaller sites there's
no contribution relation to roads
because Essex County Council do not
object to the proposal so they see an
existing access functioning for vehicles
they see a proposed one in much the same
way and their response is therefore no
objection and then I think the realities
something in relation to amenity space
so yet the level of
amenity space is set out in the report
at sorry
yes 3.39 on page six one five so the
policy guidance allows for a combination
of balcony areas and patio Gardens
communal Gardens
so the amenity space for the flats
proposed includes to the ground floor
some private amenity space to the flats
at ground floor as well as this sort of
communal area here and there's little
sort of spaces of landscaping
surrounding there as well and then all
of the flats are proposed with them the
first second and the ones right on the
top level are proposed with the minimum
balcony areas some of the balconies
greatly exceed them the minimum five
square metres and we think in this town
center location with some private space
for each of the properties that that's
acceptable in relation to that policy
requirement move on to members now then
councillor Stanley Thank You chairman it
looks like there's so many holes you
this you can call it cheese first of all
when we talk about the balconies I'm
sure that we wouldn't want to see our
children pyre or a balcony even at
second floor even at first of all or
even at first that's ground floor
children are and the five couldn't be
septa below climb in and what I view and
they'll do all they can to get out I'm
going to go on to a my usual gripe about
surface water and when it's pumped and
if this sewer if it's going to be pumped
into the sewer which it doesn't say
there is a problem because as we all
know the the top of Raley is a bowl it's
always big like there and it will always
hold water and it's got to go somewhere
so if it's
pumped out onto the road or anything
like that it's going to come down
cranial and we're going to we can all
have a canoe each and go dad cranium
as for the what's already been said have
the officers taken notice of the
boundary and its proximity to other
properties it doesn't save as though the
officers have taken anything into
consideration on that the outline of the
plane as you can see has got red lines
around it and yet is that ground owned
by the people that want to develop I
suggest not and to get cooperation from
their neighbors I suggest they won't be
doing their either where the ground
floor ease in relation to the two units
which are commercial it shows that the
doors open onto car parking spaces how
is the occupants should they have a
problem so it likely to open the door
when there is a car park there I can't
see how they can do that that's just
impossible the other thing is who he's
going to maintain the road as it's not
been adopted by a scaredy cat so when
they have no problems with it
who's going to maintain it potholes and
such you've obviously got manholes in
the road as well so who is maintaining
those sort of things
it really is it's it's it bears it bears
disbelief that we are going to put this
implant in where so much has been said
about it that I feel that you know and
it's wasting air time I really do think
that it's getting to beyond a joke that
the officers are going to mitigate
theirselves in what our policies are for
parking and everything else and it seems
to me that we're sort of hand in glove
and I don't like the idea of this there
is no amenity space for the occupants
where were they going to put the clothes
plus the fact there is
Machinery going on the roof which
doesn't show I'm afraid which it should
show and that'll make the building even
higher
it says plant is going on there there's
no light in it says there is no light in
on this document that's remove receive
no lighting for the carpark or that sort
of thing outside of that area I mean
it's just a joke
it really is I'm listening to all of
these what's going on from other other
councillors and what have you and it's
it seems to me with we're just we can
form we've got holes in this knot
there's no timorous so I would suggest I
know I believe well I do believe I
cannot support this application thank
you
okay that's revti going to the site on
Saturday we have a few questions to ask
a few of them were answered with the
presentations but the weather 106
addresses the parking management you
just show me where they're looking at
addressing the parking management on the
plan please Katie just point to the
parking management area
cities the whole part yeah okay all
right so that's fine if they're going to
do that if they can do that because it's
not owned by them the only access I'd
ask the question would it be adopted by
highways if it's brought up to a
standard we don't know because gain a
few different people I think only got
parsley access also they're trying to
encourage pedestrians with the lack of
parking but there's no pathway there
it's going to be a mixed via killer and
pedestrian Park pathway I don't know how
that would work I've seen no plans on
that just seem to be sort be of little
even after fall in his presentation I
don't know if it was or not there's no
electric charging points going to be in
there again I wanted to look at the
clean air and it's part of that so again
that seems to be missing and where
highways have said there's not going to
be no change to what happened with daily
quest but that was six years ago surely
the high street has changed since then
that's just a couple things okay sounds
of Canal
Thank You chair a couple of the the
comments from the speakers the members
and and indeed members of the committee
I've actually made me chuckle with the
way they were put forward this evening
however I don't find this a laughing
matter in deeds as a formal resident on
Rayleigh High Street the entire reason I
got involved with local politics was on
the air quality issues and the
congestion issues on that high street I
agree with the speaker and they said the
action plan quotes that if a site is
parts if part of the site is within the
conservation area the entire site is
therefore in a conservation area there
sorry the air quality area therefore and
I think it breaks our policy with
regards building materials on that
matter and our core strategy it has
explained by many of the speakers
already this evening for my Maps breaks
at least four of our core strategy
policies or an argument could be made
that it breaks at least four of our
policies surrounding parking standards
amenity space affordable housing and
size and bulk I
I appreciate the independent advice was
sought on the affordable housing
response but I would see clarity on the
reasons as to why it was felt naught
percent affordable housing was okay for
this site that's ok please Casey on this
detail of clarity with regard to the air
quality can you define the line that's
been suggested is the boundary for
members so unfortunately I haven't got a
copy of the a key I'm a pawn to hand to
show you but generally it runs along the
high street taking in the properties
that front the high street as existing
so this part of the site is in the ACMA
but the developable area isn't
okay thank you
Castle Williams yeah Thank You chairman
along with other officer other members
of the committee we visited the site
last Saturday and I'll going to keep
it's quite simple relief that I believe
this to be gross I would development
it doesn't adhere to any of our policies
and I will move now for refusal thank
you okay
you move for a fuse on Council what in
your wishing to second that or just say
second last okay would you like to state
your reasons for overdevelopment and
lacking it's not a d-ring to our policy
okay
Casa Wilson
it was a question for the officer was a
right understanding that although Essex
highways had no objection to the the
vehicle entrance off of the high street
you said something that they were
worried about pedestrian access did you
mic a bit closer yeah the did was i
right in understanding that you said the
Essex highways were happy with the
vehicle access off of the high street
but they had concerns about the
pedestrian access along there and it was
for the council which council is it is
it us so sorry let me try and make
myself clear so I had a long
conversation with them and try to
understand more fully where they're
coming from in terms of what are they
looking at into in looking at planning
applications and assessing whether or
not they object and my understanding
coming away from that is that they're
looking at the operational carriageway
if you like is there going to be any
impact on that from the development
proposal and is that impact acceptable
or could be mitigated if it was of
concern by conditions and the like and
because this development isn't seeking
to alter an existing operational access
that's adopted by the council onto the
highway there's no objection I then went
on to say do their concerns extend into
the site if you like in terms of is this
site acceptable just for instance giving
them an example if you like of the use
of this access perhaps you would argue
more involving more pedestrian usage
than was previously the case in relation
to the Derry press use and this access
is that suitable as it stands at the
moment in relation to the pedestrian and
vehicle movements going to and fro
particularly given what we know about
some of the parking issues that happen
here over this what appears to be a foot
way but actually it's not an adopted
foot way by the council along this
stretch and what I understood back from
them is that they still raise no
objection and that these matters sort of
within the site or for Rochford Council
to determine and some of our policies
that have been referenced in the report
do look to sort of pedestrian safety and
the like in dm1 for instance in terms of
all residential developments so that as
I understand it from county highways is
more of our your concern in terms of
coming to a decision about whether this
is acceptable in that regard but in
terms of the vehicle access onto the
highway
the County Council is clear that they're
not raising an objection and they don't
raise any specific concern themselves in
relation to the pedestrian movements
because I think I wasn't Sund it that's
not their main remit right Thank You
councillor Woodson thank you chairman
and we're extremely gifted in this area
to have residents members of the town
council our own councillors and people
who care and are so passionate about the
environment that we live in and they
speak with a rationale a very objective
view they don't get excited they can
they back up their reasons with our own
policies and once again we've had some
commendable presentations from members
across the district this is an
opportunist application
it pushes well it more than pushes the
boundaries
it actually insults us as a committee I
believe because we are sitting here
considering something which would be
obscene within our community for all
sorts of reasons on the car parking
front it doesn't just push the
boundaries we're talking about minimal
spaces minimal space sizes
accomodation which doesn't have any
spaces and has so being so rightly said
there aren't adjacent areas there are
roads to cross and and the whole idea of
the car parking and what are we kidding
ourselves parking management in this
particular area what does that actually
mean it sounds good but it means very
little
there should be parking management in
the area at the moment with the towing
inferring I find Essex County Council's
response wholly inadequate and it really
is just burying their head in what
becomes a cumulative problem at that
particular Junction it is a busy
Junction it's got busier over the years
and this does nothing to help the
situation at all
so I deplore the response from Essex
County Council highways the whole
building is out of character I think
people here generally would welcome some
sensible development on a on a site but
this isn't sensible development it's
overbearing it's inconsiderate to
neighbor neighbors nearby it contributes
towards the congestion and the traffic
in the area
there's ignoring of section 106
agreements there's ignoring of the
access and the highways issues there's
ignoring of the affordability aspect and
as councilor who said this business of
actively encouraging Dale not the number
of spaces it just seems to me totally
unacceptable Essex Police have commented
within the report there is no reference
to physical security in this application
as such Essex Police would like to
invite the developers to contact us yeah
we don't know the answer though so for
all sorts of reasons I really deploy
this application chair thank you for the
opportunity Thank You councillor eaves
Thank You chair I'm gonna start by
apologizing for not getting to the site
visit on the Saturday I did however
there's due to personal circumstances I
did however take the opportunity to go
there later in the day and I witnessed
what I can only classed as absolute
mayhem around the back there there were
no spark parking spaces left people were
parking there there were arguments
between drivers the concern that I have
around this is has been raised by a
number of speakers tonight that area of
land there is not owned by the developer
they hold no leverage if they want to
get that upgraded and managed who are
they going to go to they can't go to
themselves they're gonna go to the shops
and the offices that are in the front
who own the the land it I would suggest
now if they then say on the back of this
development that they're looking to put
forward that they want the the area to
be developed and they've already seen
citizen reports where they'll be done in
conjunction with the owner-occupiers of
the existing buildings at the front I am
guessing that they would be looking for
a financial contribution I think there
would be very hard-pressed to get that
the second thing I'd like to say is the
on the conclusion of the report much in
line with what everyone has said it
actually states the scale bulk height
and appearance of the proposed
development is of a design that would
not appear out of character with the
surrounding correct context or the wider
conservation area I couldn't disagree
with that more thank you check thank you
I'll just have my little say no no
you've indicated Kansas only
when we when we come to making decisions
we do have to be very mindful of the
policies that we have and the way in
which we choose to interpret them the
way in which professionals interpret
them the way in which sometimes
independent people will interpret them
and we have to be quite precise for
everyone's benefit with with with what
we say I'll go first
to Essex highways I I can appreciate
what they've said about this small
element that they're interested in which
is just the entrance onto the highway
but once you get I think it's about five
or six meters beyond that into the area
that is not adopted highway then the
officers have suggested that a section
106 would be sufficient to deal with the
traffic management I think that there
are so many variables in this so many
different interested parties not least
of which is our own a transport
department who filmed that the been
tracking glory the tracking for the bin
lorries might not work I feel that we do
need some detail on this rather than
just accepting that it's something that
could be resolved in a longer discussion
so I'm not I'm not happy with that the
detail of the interaction between
pedestrians there's an entrance to a
restaurant along there there's clearly
the opportunity for people going to the
gym for it to the residential properties
I do think we need detail and I I would
be happy to support a reason for refusal
that there is lack of clarity on how the
in the safe interaction would work with
parking pedestrians and access to
necessary service vehicles when we get
on to 0.3 101 which is on page six
. to four we have the paragraph which
talks about the the reasoning for the
section 106 we're stuck with educate a
succession they've got their policy we
think it's staff the don't disagree with
that that the health a that they have a
threshold before they they start
requesting contributions I don't get
that I mean if anyone was to ask any of
us can we think of a scheme to give you
some money we'd snap it up but they they
seem to have some sort of different
values so but with the affordable houses
that's within our control we have we as
a council not the developer we have
commissioned an independent assessment
and that is that that assessment has
said on this rare occasion and I do
agree with what counselor Steptoe said I
can't recall another occasion when there
has been no request for affordable
housing but that is what the independent
assessment of our Commission has come up
with I would find it hard to put that as
a reason for refusal based on what has
been said but should other reasons for
refusal come to light then I would as an
informative that that assessment needs
to be revisited and we need to take a
perhaps a second opinion because two
members that is so clearly something
that is that is very controversial the
the point has been made about the
overdevelopment scale and high the the
parking now that's quite a challenging
one because we do know and we have many
examples of town centre locations where
the parking standard can be less we've
accepted that in the past but on a
relatively fresh knock down and restart
development our preferred parking bay
sizes I don't I don't I don't see any
reason why that that should be a be
overwritten but in terms of the number
of spaces if it is a conflict it is a
town center location we can assume that
people won't have cars but we we've also
got a duty through our wider
responsibilities through planning to be
promoting other modes of transport and
if you haven't got anywhere to put a car
in the first place then that is going to
promote bus travel it is going to remit
promote train travel so it's a difficult
one but I'd be fully happy to support a
reason around around the physical
parking sizes and then I think we've got
some more information to come about the
air quality because I think we've had a
bit more of a look on the on the detail
so I'll come back to officers now for
further detail on the air quality
because that that was some some detail
so firstly I apologize to the gentleman
sat in the corner over there we have
clarified it because what's important is
we get this right this is the
decision-making on the night so what we
have in front of me and unfortunately I
don't have the ability to show you the
outline of the air quality management
area now but the it's a little unclear
because the what's on the ground in
terms of the outline of buildings looks
a bit different to this but part of this
bit of the building that's proposed
looks to me like it does form part of
the air quality management area so it's
a slither
but it does mean that's part of the
developable site does fall within the
air quality management area so members
might want to be very mindful of that
and the policy does seek to restrict new
residential development within that area
but the majority of site is not within
that area potentially there is
insufficient information to judge
whether the flats or part of the
blaster proposed within that bit of the
site that does fall within the area are
appropriate or not given that
information we have had instances where
we have accepted residential development
in the hom a further up the high street
to the west because of the arrangement
of fenestration which wouldn't allow
which would essentially not face the
high street if you like because this is
where the pollution is coming from and
vehicle movements around in there so
potentially it's its lack of information
around that come back to members for a
second time in a moment but i think we
have probably had the opportunity to
explore all of the key issues around
this so can we start to focus down onto
the motion for refusal and further
comments prior to councillor Counsell
Williams restating his reason cancer
Stanley yeah cancer Stanley can sir
Stanley first before Thank You chairman
first of all I thought the point yes we
do need accommodation for our residents
but in by getting this accommodation and
I quite agree with you while your
statement but at the same time are we
not asking those people that buy those
properties when they come to sell them
they'll sell them at a reduced rate or
reduced Christ on there because there is
no parking they are only able to sell to
somebody that doesn't want parking and
that's not to prove that all those that
want to buy they might have vehicles
belonging to their companies to use and
they've got nowhere to put them and they
won't put them in companies won't allow
them to put in car parks we're not under
an attending so there is somewhat of a
the evaluation if you like this is
discriminatory because of of not
allowing we expect people to buy
property to to live and and to work from
most properties are to live and to work
from Guruji's car park areas whatever so
this is this is really descriptive
building as I'll call it in the way of
not allowing not allowing people to have
the same as everybody else
yes I do agree that on the IQ ma power
we've got just more than that shop on
the corner we've actually got the
driveway into it which they are
proposing to put into their estate if
you like so it's not just that little
corner it's all of that parking area
it's all of that driving in for vehicles
and everything else so we must be
mindful of that because it shows it
there in in rate the line shows you in
outline and they are the developers are
making it part of their development
which should indicate to us that it is
in that IQ MA and not just the buildings
at the back
Thank You Jeremy thank you right we'll
come back to you now sir Williams to
restate please your reasons for grille
use the refusal would be that is my in
my consideration this would be over
development of this site it doesn't a
deer the the application is an idea to
our our policies I have serious concerns
over the security of the site and also
the access to the site
yeah I think we do need to sort be
precise about the reasons for refusal
from what I've heard tonight there's
been a number of concerns raised in
relation to so the in terms of the
overdevelopment what I think I'd need to
understand is what that relates to in
which aspect of the site so is it the
scale and massing of the building
relation to neighboring properties and
the impact on amenity or is the
overdevelopment to do with the scale and
mass in relation to the character of the
area or it or is the is it to do with
the amount of parking that can be
provided in it being inadequate in
relation to the number of units that are
proposed so I think I need a bit more
information about over development and a
bit more detail and also in relation to
the sort of dozen are data policies we
can relate the policies to the reasons
for refusal and officers can do that but
so I don't think number two dozen today
two policies I think we need to come we
just on pick the overdevelopment one
first was yes to all of those actually
okay overbearing for the for the area
considering the fact that it also
borders on to Dutch cottage I believe
that if I could suck on that
um so I think from from the discussions
that we've had all together I've
understood that there is concern about
the overdevelopment of this building in
terms of the site the amount of the site
that's available for parking and the
numbers so is that does that form part
of this element of and I think we need
to unpick about this parking being
insufficient is that solely relating to
the fact that proposed that new
occupants of this block wouldn't have
access sufficiently to car parking and
might park ad hoc to the inconvenience
of existing nearby residents etc are we
also including within that an impact in
terms of the loss of a parking that is
existing to nearby properties or is it
solely to do with thee it's both okay
and were you happy to accept the point
that I made about the prefer the
preferred parking standard the size of
the bays more than happy yes the the
other point that I got from members was
and I mentioned myself was about the the
detail of the the management of the area
not directly within the planning
application the traffic management
around that was necessary the concerns
with regard to the tracking of the
refuse vehicles and detail within that
yeah so I think if that's okay the first
reason for refusal relates to over
development in terms of the amount of
the site available given the size of the
building to provide sufficient parking
which would not be sufficient for a
proposed occupants of the development
but also have an adverse impact on the
parking of existing commercial uses got
that one am i including just while we're
on that one anything else in relation to
over development in terms of the scale
and massing of the building or is it
solely relating to the parking issue so
just focusing really on these
so so there the overall bomb can hide
the the impact from the the various
directions of of site of these and they
start relating to the impact of the
character or I know we've had concerns
raised in relation to neighboring
properties but if you have any concerns
in relation to that I think we need to
be specific if there's not concerns
relating to that we equally need to
understand that its nature comes from
councillor Wilson who's moving there
thank you that's it concerns regarding
the the whole area those conditions the
character character
forgive me did you did you include your
concerns about air quality within I
didn't have any any issues on air
quality but you might choose for members
satisfaction to include that within the
informative particularly around the the
106 can I can I go back to these so I've
got one reason for refusal around over
development and I'm sorry to labor the
point but if this goes to appeal we do
need to understand what we are trying to
support the counseling in in their
reasons for refusal and what an
inspector might consider so in relation
to the overdevelopment point at the
moment i've got parking in relation to
parking insufficient list c and the
scale of the building including the
plant to the to the roof and the impact
on the character that's all I've got at
the moment in relation to over
development this I think the second
reason for refusal would relate to the
access so separately in relation to the
access and potentially inadequacy of
information to for the council to be
satisfied that that access that's not in
the ownership of the applicant at the
moment can work satisfactorily in terms
of the turning of the refuse vehicles
and the control of the parking around
that and the the access in terms of the
pedestrian and vehicle movements
adjacent to each other and the safety
that along with the lack of amenities in
perhaps them possibility of this
overlooking the school can are I think
we have to be careful about some areas
where we haven't had a discussion and
and the the thing about overlooking the
school is one that I think is a
sensitive one because simply simply
being bordering on to a school it's not
a problem there are hundreds of
thousands of properties up and down the
country that do that it's people that
cause a problem with with schools and I
think we have to be careful about just
throwing out comments because we think
we need to ensure that what we're saying
is able to be substantiated my main
concerns are over development for this
one okay
cancer Stanley you just want to assist
gouts the Wilson right Betty Williams
sorry
right okay obviously you're aware that
that goes against the officers advice
and analysis of the application sorry I
didn't catch that can you explain to
what what the comment was that just it
was about a lack of amenity space I
think we we had concerns in the report
in the application that suggested that
the amenity space available was further
for the town center location was not
close enough yeah
is the is the is the concern about the
amenity space for their proposed flats
being incorporated into the
overdevelopment reason for fusil or not
yes yes okay so I've got two reasons for
refusal at the moment I've got one over
development one and one related to the
access vehicle pedestrian movements I
know we can we can put the policies
relating to those but there was
something about security that I didn't
there was within the the report
reference that the standard of design
would be based on the secured by design
standard six police on six to seven but
we didn't the men I believe members
didn't feel that they had sufficient
detail in the application to see that
that was actually happening I say what I
would perhaps suggest is that's an
informative that would be put on and to
say that you know in any subsequent
application what you'd want to see is
that you know that's been given full
consideration into the the the the other
two items were because we wouldn't like
to signee these elements offers been
accepted one was the 106 and a second
opinion on that is that going on as an
informative informative
because there is a formal so the
informative would state that for any
subsequent application I think that's a
piece of work that we also if you like
so we would just sit and the air quality
issue and the precise clarity of
adjoining part of the site is is perhaps
more fully explored is that him an
informative or is that a reason for
refusal if that's the reason for refusal
about insufficient information regarding
the part of the site being in the air
quality Monteria yeah counsel watson you
like help counsel Williams for these
reasons for refusal chairman as I said
earlier we've listened to a number of
very good speakers tonight some that
form parts of the committee and some
that don't but nevertheless they came up
with well reasoned points in relation to
our policies but you need to make that
that could I suggest that the tape is
listened back because we were broadly
supportive of those we were but as
members of the committee it is for you
to put forward the reasons for refusal
that's quite clear cancer Stanley
close proximity to other properties
can I just just clarify so in turn can I
go back to the layout plan please I know
we have heard concerns from one resident
in particular and we've had some
discussion from various members about
the impact in terms of residential
amenity I need to understand I think in
terms of the reason for a fuse or which
parts of the site you're concerned with
so for instance is it this part of the
site and you're concerned with the
impact in terms of amenity and the
proximity to boundaries there's a car
park here for instance so I sort of
assume there's no concern in relation to
that here property 7a is here with its
residential garden and we've heard the
concerns raised from from the occupant
of that property in relation to the
proximity to this boundary given the
scale of the development Stanly 7a yeah
that's Williams is that that acceptable
for yes acceptable yes thank you
okay right members without prejudging
what what you're about to determine I
think it's fairly clear the direction in
which this is this is gone we've had a
full discussion we have a motion for
refused almost has been foot forward and
seconded we have a series of reasons for
refused on which are clearly understood
by officers does any member need to have
those reasons for if you don't restated
so they're clear about what there have
been going to be asked to vote on okay
right to the vote then those members in
favor of the refusal please indicate
thank you that item is refused we now
move on to item seven which is land to
the east of the Rugby Club aviation way
Rochford
[Music]
chairman if I may um I'd like to I have
a non-paternity interests being a ward
councillor for this one Oh same reason
chairman Bing war council thank you very
much
right okay okay thank you Jeff and good
evening members right this is a reserved
matters application in respect of
landscaping only it is not a planning
application but merely an application
for further approval of reserved matters
further to the granting of previous
reserved matters and the fifth under
planning reference 1800 at 5:00 it for
REM which dealt with issues of siting
external appearance layout and access
and landscaping so we're not revisiting
issues of siting external appearance
layout and access and we are revisiting
for a second time issues of landscaping
only the original application in terms
of the outline permission was planning
reference 1500 781 or UT which is the
outline which granted approval for the
principle of b1 and b2 use on the Y the
site which is in connection with the
joins every action plan as aviation way
so the the site hiring question is
consistent with the previous application
the 1800 500 REM the entire site is aged
in red here if I recall was about 2.4
heck days which is about 24,000 square
meters the application in this instance
has sort of three main elements a source
set of the landscaping scheme those
elements are land level changes the
actual landscaping itself and enhanced
boundary treatments so just to give
members an outline
this is aviation way along here this is
unit 16 to 17 unit 18 to 19 and units 20
to 21 in terms of this is north so
basically the site's broadly is 190
meters in length along here 200 meters
in length along its West boundary 200
meters in length along its southern
boundary and it is 143 meters in length
along its east boundary we can move on
to the next slide please so in terms of
this layout here shows the substantive
reserve matters that has been approved
under the approval the 1800 504 rem so
this elements here is unchanged as is
really the actual extent and location of
the landscape buffer the main changes
are in this area around here which will
show you from the photographs so broadly
the area that has been subject to
changes in land levels is broadly 7,200
square metres as compared to the overall
site area of 24,000 square metres so
we're only talking about land level
changes mainly along this path the site
fundamentally the question is why then
so there's a slight fall in land levels
from west to east and from Northwest to
Southeast
and basically the works have been
undertaken it'd be helpful to members
perhaps if we moved on to sure
photograph which is quite helpful which
is the next slide or the slide for but
that's yet there we go
so although not entirely in this white
area so what we have here is that the
mainland level changes are along a
ninety seven meter length along this
southern boundary here but as the report
also mentions there are land level
changes to a length of 22 metres broad
along the east so basically it's to
create a level site which wasn't
appreciated at the time the original
reserve matters was submitted and there
are there are there a number of reasons
obviously ones requiring a level site
which is to ensure that this vertical
alignment with the spine rod if we
perhaps moved on to one of the pictures
one of a spine if we just move on
through the pictures perhaps
there's maybe go back but that's fine so
so basically under a separate reserved
matters application a spine rod serving
part of a site have been approved and
therefore to get vertical alignment with
the spine rod here we are the spine rod
here which is to the west of the site so
currently then the building is
substantially complete in terms of its
shell so we're looking at the site we'll
progress with each photograph that will
be shown through an O in an easterly
direction but the main reasons it can
just stop there for a moment the main
reasons then for the levelling of the
land is because obviously the land does
need to be level which facilitates
vertical alignment with a spine rod to
get a level area because from a previous
plan showed what you have to the south
of the actual building itself which is
about thirteen thousand thirteen
thousand square meters is that the the
site does need to be level and also to
facilitate drainage of surface water off
that surface yard back in a northerly
direction in the direction of the
building and also the third reason is to
facilitate an integrated landscaping
scheme so the land falls from west to
east therefore so if we can which will
just take you through so basically this
photograph there's a series of
photographs now and I think photographs
speak evolved it speaks volumes
so this 97 meter length of strip
generally just explain to members that
the the width of this area to the rear
of particularly eighteen and nineteen
aviation way and to a lesser degree 20
in 21 aviation way the actual width of
that strip to the boundary is 3.5 meters
the area here has been raised and I'm
going to show you actually some section
drawings if we just move in turn through
the drawings
okay so so basically what what the
section drawings show is just explain to
members the this section here is a very
telling section so this is a section
looking east to west so it's a
transverse section looking across the
ninety seven meter line where the
weather land levels have been changed so
the green dotted line shows the existing
are the pre-work land levels and the the
solid black line shows the actual land
levels as they have been undertaken so
this here is the actual site boundary so
one can appreciate that actually what's
actually taking place is that currently
from the site boundary the green dashed
line disorder an actual Bund at the
moment which is the green dotted line so
fundamentally the works that have not
taken place yet is the scraping of this
Bund
on the southern side of the of the race
land level and at this point here
there's going to be a writ a concrete
retaining wall which a works yet to be
undertaken which is going to be partly
in the ground sitting on a plinth on a
concrete plinth so the actual vertical
height of this concrete retaining wall
which is roughly located over three
metres from the site boundary the
vertical height of this wall is going to
be one meter and basically as this is
the most telling section drawing which
is a representation along the
longitudinal plane looking at it
transverse so the main differential is
is that the land is actually built up
beyond the line of the proposed location
of the retaining wall
at an angle because it needs to
basically fill in this area here so this
is the area looking east so so
fundamentally it's just filling in that
area where there was a fall in the land
and the officer report does indicates
that although it's not this is a
representation through the longitudinal
line the highest differential and land
level is actually 1.5 meters which is
indicated by that section drawing and
this here is a shot looking in the other
direction so these are just section
drawings showing you the representations
through the site if you move on to the
next drawing right what this actually
shows and it's important to emphasize is
as the land falls from west to east the
actual dates and points for the highest
part of the building the highest part of
the building is no higher than the
previously identified datum point in the
five it four REM application but as
there's a gradual fall in the land there
is a slight make up of land levels here
but actually doesn't result in actually
a higher building and it's quite
important to emphasize that so perhaps
you'll just go through some of the
photographs now which will help us to
consider and conclude on some of the
main issues if we just go through each
one one by one
so yeah I'd like to show member so
basically in terms of the land level
changes this is at the rear of eighteen
to nineteen aviation way it's rather
dark this picture but basically that is
this area here actually represents what
is the highest point then so just to
just to confirm that the land levels as
you see them at this highest point will
get no higher and the one thing to
emphasize as well is is that the highest
land level relative to that green dotted
line that you saw at its highest point
the greatest differential is no more
than 300 millimeters relative to the top
of the bund that was shown on that
previous section drawing it was denoted
by the green dotted line so if you just
go through the photographs please this
actual if you go back one please so just
to show you the photographs then we'll
go on to the just the main points in the
appraisal but I just want to show
members this so this is a shot of the
reel of eighteen and nineteen aviation
way just to show you the arrangements at
the rear of this premises so there are
windows looking out towards the sites
and there's what can be described as a
conservative structure here you just
move on to the next one please this is
an image looking from west to east then
along the rear of eighteen to nineteen
aviation way so you can appreciate the
physical sort of relationship between
this building and this changed land
level here just go on through the next
one please this is a an image what
basically emerges from from observations
on situs so this is the westerly
extremity of eighteen and nineteen
aviation way looking towards number
sixteen and seventeen aviation way so as
we move along the site boundary to the
west the actual level differentiation
basically pizzas out it becomes
indiscernible almost so that's coincides
with that whole concept of the Ville and
sort of drops away from from where
to east in this direction now the next
photograph please this is quite a useful
shot this shot is taken of the building
and this image is taken at the East
extremity of 16 to 17 Aviation we're
looking through so the land level
bearing in mind members that there was
an existing Bund here anyway it's just
this is this is where the
differentiation stats to occur which
basically coincide with that first image
I showed members in terms of that very
white have compacted area so it's core
terminus with that we can just move on
again please Katie and this is just to
give members a clearer image of of this
change so just to explain in what was
explained in the section drawing
basically at this point here this is
this the Bund that will be scraped away
so the actual retaining wall will be
along here so the 1 meter vertical
concrete wall will be at this point here
and this area from here to here will be
scraped the way to give that vertical
wall emphasis we move on again please
Katie and this is an image taken right
at the bottom end of 18 to 19 aviation
way which is this is the building and
this is the East boundary of the site so
again when one stands here there is a an
element of an embankment there to the
same heights as what's shown broadly
along the southern boundary we're going
to come to sort of the main points but
we can just finish the photographs
please that's the last one okay right so
just that the main issue so members have
an opportunity to consider that there's
one on landscaping this summer as well
Katie landscaping plan
so that's the in terms of the the
outline of the land level changes MEMS
are not that the second aspect was the
landscaping so what I will explain to
Mendez is is that all I can conclude is
from the landscaping perspective what we
have here we have a swale here which is
an area of ground which was designed as
part of the outline phase in terms of
the infrastructure strategy there's
going to be a swale here where water
will drain into this area so in terms of
the extent of the actual landscaping
buffer strip and it's mentioned in the
report so what we have here is a is a
mixture of sort of native shrub plants
this this here is just showing the
extent of the boundary wall which is in
this area here so it's only over a part
of half of the length of a southern
boundary where the actual wall will be
erected so in terms of comparing the
appropriateness of a landscaping element
of the planting itself this is actually
very similar to the previous plan that
was approved under the 1800 v it for REM
application and it's in line with the
broad principle set at an outline stage
so in terms of landscaping and the
design islands of landscaping is
concluded that the application is
satisfactory and then there enhance
boundary treatments well that was shown
really on the section drawing which
really is the retaining wall and then we
have a shot of we've thoughts of
perimeter fencing detail somewhere and
basically members will note from the
report that the pod in fence is
basically a high tensile steel mesh
boundary and this this fence will sit
actually not 0.5 meters further into the
site at the height of the retaining wall
so it will extend at a height setback
not 0.5 meters further into the service
yard on the northern side of the bone
three so just to just to conclude a few
issues then and to so we're clear that
the part of this application does seek
retrospective permission for the
remaining works that's be undertaken
which is the scraping of the buns to
create that level area to the base of
the wall on the southern side it
includes the erection of the plug-in
fence which is pretty much along the
south south east and west boundaries and
then the buffer planting so given the
narrow scope of the application it's my
recommendation that the reserved matters
be approved subject to the three
conditions as outlined in the officer
reports thank you
two speakers on this one is it mr.
Ryan's [ __ ] to point out on the free
older to 16 or 17 18 to 19 19 to 21 of
aviation why I've owned the property for
23 years and the buns ever took me in
the farmer some years ago the bun was
only about 600 millimeters high about
two feet in our language the bun that
obviously didn't come up above my wind
outside didn't cause any problem that
blend used to be level I was like there
is a photograph for some reason haven't
picked up there as when I put the
property the land was level with the
fields at the rear now now the bun now
is now seven feet high so you're being
misled by your planners it's actually
1.5 meters too high to what was
originally approved which is a five feet
the bun was roughly two feet so we're
seven feet so we're really we're up to
nearly 3/4 way up with top of our
winders so I've lost one tenant already
due to the noise because obviously it is
a lot of banging and crashing going on
there when you got our height you should
really have some kind of critic fencing
it's cut the light out the lights on now
all day long
electricity comes from the airport so we
pay twice the price anyone else does for
electricity we have no choice and that
one there's no drainage or language to
drain onto the land next door and there
it can't because of the
their levels of the ground they say
they're going to put retaining wall up
they can't build the retaining wall that
guards a mile and to build it so I'd
like to know they're going to build it
from that Bank downwards and secondly
there are no drainage on the bottom of
the retaining wall so once again where
is that we're going to dry and where it
used to drain before it can't drain on
the site because it's going to be a
retaining wall there so I'm just asked
what I'd like really is is its members
it's possible to have a site visit so
they could see for themself and
appreciate the impact caused by this 1.5
meter increase in the ground levels also
they can see the historic pillbox now
which we only see the roof for now which
before you could see the pillbox the
plans were approved or misleading they
or should I show lamb between us and the
new IP Co building being level that's
what it was originally approved they
were run in the first place it was more
pointed out to the council in July I
actually got my own engineer to check
the levels to prove the levels were
wrong I'm to that time your planning
department didn't even know they're all
wrong so that's Warren isn't it these
are the people that are voicing you
right originally this area land was to
be a car park which was approved
originally and then it was changed to a
service yard the car park was 450
million is lower and could have had a
slope on it because it's a service yard
it needs to be level so it can go into
the base so the lorries can go into the
back of the building at a level platform
with the ground with the inside slab
I'm not against any any difficult many
facts I also on the land will opposite
side in Cherry Orchard brickwork so I'm
for the development or what I'm
concerned about is that we seem to be
robbed shot over over you know the
existing tenants which caused major
major problems with us and and Southend
Council seemed about to do whatever they
liked it and watch they just back them
up I really would like the members to
come and have a look for their own sake
so they can make a minyan based on facts
rather than a fiction you're getting
from your planning I have two tenants
that complained in writing one of the
antennas have moved out I have taken
legal advice and my solicitors are
waiting to start actually if necessary
you stylin shouldn't mind going back to
the side five minutes
Thank You chair my name is Nick diamond
I'm a planning partner at night Frank
the application before you followed
extensive discussions with you offices
and we welcome their conclusions that
the proposed works would not result in
any demonstrable harm to any development
plan interests the character and
appearance of the area nor amenity of
neighboring commercial units and that it
permits drainage to be dealt with
entirely within our clients site with no
surface water runoff to the adjoining
land to the south a position that has
been confirmed by both officers and Kent
County Council members should also when
looking at this application obviously
consider the merits of the application
before them and if they are satisfied
approved the application by way of
background and as pointed out by your
office's outline planning was granted
for the entire site back in 2015 and a
reserved matters application dealing
with the appearance and scale of the
building which occupies the site and
will has been as has been said
previously be occupied by a picot along
with the car parking and servicing was
approved in 2018 the application before
you seeks a further reserved matters
approval to landscaping details
including changes to levels which were
not in the previous reserved matters
application access Arrangements scale
layout and appearance of the debate verb
development remain as previously
approved under the 2018 reserved matters
application the reserved matters
application if approved would sit
alongside the previous reserved matters
permission and there is nothing that
prevents there being a number of
reserved matters applications coming
forward especially on large and complex
sites such as this
I would respectfully request that you
follow your officers recommendation and
approved the planning application
thereby enabling delivery of the first
phase of development as conceived by
your joint area action plan and ensuring
that the provision of a modern
accommodation for a significant
long-standing local employer is
delivered Thank You chairman Thank You
Steptoe Thank You chair I just ought to
clarify not only my County Council for
this area I'm also the ward councillor
for this area as well just to clarify is
it possible we could I could have the
picture up of the landscape you know
where it had to swell on it as well
place it okay um the water
I think the officer said and I'd ask the
committee to question this runs from
left to right across this drawing in
other words west to east it doesn't show
where it ends up and I'd like to know
perhaps where the water does end up into
secondly when this was a greenfield site
obviously the drainage from the adjacent
property in Asia Aviation way would have
run into the fields and then and simply
soaked away I'd like to ask the
committee to find out what the
mitigation has been put in place as part
of this to alleviate that particular
problem was there any data taken pray
the previous to the it being done as we
would on any other development site I'm
assuming that also this is a
retrospective application which I find a
little strange considering who's doing
development and I think that just about
covers everything that I've got too
concerned with but mainly how is that
water that's running from north from
south to north under what was the
original prop field being dealt with
terms of mitigation perhaps the planning
committee get those points clarified for
me okay no more of our non-members
council Stanley you'd indicated first
yeah thank you German in respect of
what's just been said and I quite
ignored that that is part of parcel of
my asking the officer but at the same
time with the Fung that was
approximately six hundred mill and there
it's much higher this is obviously a
conflict to the adjoining premises where
they're looking they're looking at the
the bank instead of looking across away
from it and this is quite a high level
plus the fact that along with this it's
going to be used as a lorry park car
park whatever that may be
this is really sort of a going this I'll
call it co2 whatever you like to call it
nitrous oxides whatever coming off of
that parking area from diesel fumes and
what-have-you
how can how can premises actually
survive if that is the case you know I
mean this is again another another put
you put one building up at the detriment
of somebody else which is already got a
building there and it's occupied and
he's likely to lose just likely to lose
the revenue from it and also the labor
or the employment if you like to that
premises the other thing is the where we
got the swell if you like how is that
being discharged and is the water that's
the other side of that ban because nari
can't fall into that swell or their area
where is that going we all know that the
reason that the the bun was there was to
either age stop flooding into the
premises adjacent to it but there
doesn't seem to be any anything dumb in
respect of that property the other side
plus the fact is the wall going to be
built on the property of the ownership
to that site and not on the ownership to
the what the gentleman has just said he
owns and quite frankly to remove that
and just put a concrete pillar in there
who is going to maintain that as we all
know that the concrete will gradually
rot away because of corrosion by the
soil clay is one really bad thing that
really rots a concrete very very quickly
who is going to maintain that their area
as well thank you German just remind
everyone we're on a particularly narrow
item of a planning application here I
think just just to how members along the
the petite we've got a valid application
on this side this is a variation on
reserve matters could I just ask you to
give a little bit more detail on the
impact of the surface water drainage on
surface water drainage compared to what
we've previously applied that agreed
well have to respond by saying initially
that given that this is to deal with
landscaping we are simply not dealing
with surface water drainage as a massive
consideration this evening because it's
landscaping and landscaping is defined
in the planning acts as a very narrow
scope it does not involve surface water
drainage however just the impact on it
officers recognized that in raising land
levels we have to be satisfied that the
narrow scope of this application does
not affect the ability of the
application
object to the previous outline
permission 1500 78 1 outline a condition
22 stated that in connection with each
dev elements of each path so that came
forward under each separate reserved
matters application that the surface
water drainage in respect of each parcel
had to be resolved but that is a
resolution to be found under condition
22 of the outline planning consent
however when we see this application
which cited site level changes officers
were immediately alert to the potential
that's the requirements required under a
separate planning consent may not be
achieved because of these site level
changes so to answer the question in
terms of although it is actual material
fact that we are not looking at surface
water drainage this evening
the reason I've bought this plan along
is because officers had a meeting with
the developer with the developer and
Essex suds in Chelmsford a while ago and
we were looking at this issue of raised
land levels as it related to did affect
the fundamental delivery of the surface
water drainage mechanisms that are
required and receptor condition and
receptor planning consents how things
have evolved from that is is that Essex
suds are satisfied that these land level
changes fundamentally do not affect the
delivery of surface water drainage the
reason for showing that plan is is that
in terms of how the run would work
members will note that I did present in
the presentation earlier on that that
one of the objectives of the getting the
site level was the second objective was
to achieve surface water runoff off the
service yard so there's a number of
things that have been confirmed there
that along these levels here
what's the this plan Shores which isn't
necessarily submitted in connection with
this application have emphasized but
it's submitted in relation to details
relating to condition 22 discharge of
condition to Institue of the outline
relating to the surface water drainage
details of this parcel of land so what
these spot levels actually show then and
as the section drawings that were shown
the land basically says at its highest
point here and it drops back in the
direction of the building so the whole
idea is that when it rains heavily water
will actually what will be draining from
this area to this area here and of all
very complicated the the issues in terms
the drainage Swale they are subject of
separate consideration under the under
condition 22 the outline which suds have
confirmed wood is acceptable and the
fundamentally what we need to be looking
at is what are the implications for
surface water drainage and that's in the
report as a result of these of this
narrow scope of this consideration and
the answer is that there is no
implication for service water drainage I
would just like to add one more thing is
that the developer has confirmed in
writing with a council that actually
there is no drainage op C coming from
the site in the direction of a southern
boundary thank you chairman I'd like to
recommend that we defer this application
no members at the site visit then we did
we'd be able to see a bit more what it's
been said a lot clearer personally feel
that we have got everything that we need
in the way of information to support is
making a decision tonight on a very
narrow focused application and we clear
how clearly have all in the detail about
very specific height levels available to
us III think it would be unfair and
members that have obviously had to had
the opportunity to call a site visit in
advance of this if they found it was
appropriate so I was well I'm not
supportive of that person at the moment
that's ref T can you go back to this
cross-section slide it showed two
different scene ground levels between
what was and what's now proposed please
all right with the middle picture where
the green line is where the green line
used to come up on the South border used
to come right to where the shroud was
the shell wall was gonna be blue BT
there yeah with the old site there was
the new ground level looks like it's
gonna be a greater fall going towards
the South than there was originally
what's what's the no we're not supposed
to talk about ground water and stuff
like that but that's not going towards
the building that is going towards the
south boundary and that he's a lot
bigger than what it was do we know what
impact that will have yes I didn't cover
that in my presentation but it's I've
already covered it in my presentation
that you've got a vertical one meter
wall here where this existing Bund has
been scraped away so it leaves you with
a vertical emphasis of one meter and
this is on the southern boundary so 18th
1980 Asian Way is on this side of the
boundary so land and slopes up beyond
the wall to a point about four meters
from the the wall so this highest point
which is where the greatest differential
in land level is as looking at the site
from the east I said what I'm getting at
is you've now got a four meter drop its
Awards the South where before you never
had
no that's incorrect you have a 1 meter
drop from the top of the wall to the
bottom of the scrape 1 meter not 4
meters I was showing where the highest
point is he's a for me it's for me to
the highest point use 4 meter from the
south boundary is that correct
no so I think correct am I not insane
I've explained everything I can explain
to Mendez I'm sorry Brett German doctor
it may be L to assist the green dashed
line which is perhaps somewhat difficult
to see him in on the background of this
of mustard color but the green dashed
line shows the level prior to some of
these works having taken place to
increase the land level yeah yeah so
from this point here that so the the
lowest level of the green line as was to
the highest point that it's been raised
yeah this plan indicate that that
distance is 1.5 meters and that's the
highest differential from the existing
to the to the what is now yes this
weighs 1.5 level 5 meters at this point
here here and this is section BB which
is this here so this point here is right
on the boundary and then this point here
is just slightly what yet 4 meters into
the site this area here if you're
concerned with this here yes so in terms
of the slight increase in the the slope
if you like upwards or downwards towards
the southern boundary this area is the
land near bit that's going to be
landscapes or soft landscaping on there
so we haven't got the landscaping plan
on the layout but that's the bit they'll
be soft landscape between the the pup
can't pronounce it with the fence that
will go up just on top of the retaining
wall and then you'll have a strip here
which has soft landscaping in it and
that goes along this boundary here this
dark line here is the service yard so
that soft landscaping will drain down
into these as well
and it'll be soft if you like so the
surface essentially will take some sorry
I'm just gonna add so here so this so
yep so this this part here is where the
highest point is at 1.5 G's yeah along
here and then as it moves back towards
the service yard it Peters out to about
30 centimeters difference any surface
water runoff that actually doesn't run
back to the building will actually run
along the retaining wall that's the
purpose of one of the reasons why the
retaining wall was actually put in and
then run back towards the swell or out
here to pick up the existing surface
water drainage Thank You chair and just
wanted to clarify how this came to our
attention and the the retrospective
nature of it were there any reasons
given as to why this was I think we need
to focus on whether we agree with this
rather than the reasons behind it it's
just to focus on the application as it
stands for Jews but is the retrospective
nation that you're of it not some cereal
masa no thank you for not sure cath
Reeves
Noguchi being mindful of your direction
to members that we had the opportunity
to call in a site meeting before I think
that is a valid thing to actually ask
for deferment for sites was it purely
and simply for the reason that we seem
to have conflicting information coming
from the adjoining people from as was
explained to us tonight compared to what
has actually physically been presented
to us tonight and that site visit would
clarify them
Thank You chair I mean it is
acknowledged in the in the officers
report that there is an impact with
regards to how the site levels are an
error in conjunction and with the
adjoining landowner the officer I mean
obviously we did take that into
consideration that's why we have a
reserve additional reserved matters
application before the committee tonight
the officer has spoken his report that
we've taken the impact on the
neighboring amenity into consideration
members should be mindful that we are
talking about two business developments
here and obviously although there is a
level of immunity it's not the level of
immunity that would be expected if it
was a residential development that was
nearby the adjoining landowner mentions
about impact on light but this is light
too you know commercial premises and
we're considered that the actual
distance between the back of their
premises and actually where this raised
land levels are isn't material to have
such a negative impact on that amenity
that they should be expected to enjoy
family you wanted to come back if I may
please check from from my understanding
from the Senior Planner there is only
one concrete wall could you indicate
that to me please
it's along this length here so this
annotation shows the wall will extend 97
meters from the southeast boundary along
the boundary to this point here of wet
wet will no longer be required can I
just turn and say then that I've just
been told by the planning officer that
the concrete wall is that side of the
green and not this sort of the green
that's have been indicated by your
senior planner who is right and who is
wrong sorry cherry tip later men say
that there is a concrete wall running
along okay very H just let the officers
to clarify yeah I want to clarify please
the concrete wall is inside that the
applicants boundary it's not even in
third party land obviously because the
nortis have been served so this here
this doesn't actually show where the
wall is this is the an annotation and
arrow showing where the wall is inside
the actual site boundary that's what I
was taking to Berlin yes so that's false
key the reason I'm asking is is the bung
that was originally there is in the
developer's property or is it the
property of the adjoining business and
if there is the case then don't we'll
have to cut their car park then or lorry
park to make sure that okay can we just
focus on the narrow application that's
in front of it I need to just
temporarily halt proceedings I mean it
our meetings go two and a half hours and
this one finishes at ten o'clock
unless you will the majority of you will
agree that we continue the meeting
members we have one more application in
front of us as well for which mr. Mason
cancel mr. Mason has been waiting quite
patiently the members I move that we
continue the meeting tyll tyll tyll
completes our car I don't anticipate the
next one being a huge length of
armed remembers happy to continue the
meeting great okay right
just for clarity counts ashore you you
you indicated that you will prefer this
item to be deferred pending a site visit
it sort I think counts are ft indicated
that he seconded obviously I expressed
my mock my view but I think given where
we are and the slide impasse we'll take
a vote on your motion for deferral does
anyone else wish to speak on that motion
for deferral now those members in favor
of deferring this item subject to a site
visit please indicate those against the
item is deferred ending site visit sorry
about that
right moving on item 8 ghost at all farm
ghost at all
lane or well
yeah sorry just getting personal no
Katie that's the location plastic
innings
just the location plan thank you yes
that's fine
members so this application is for the
change of you system exist in poultry
sheds and the site is located to the
south of main road and close to the
junction with gusted Hall Lane if it can
take you to the next plan please so this
shows you the wider context so this is
the site here and the existing poultry
sheds that are not usual not used for
that purpose any longer this is gusted
hall lane running up to some residential
properties here but surrounding is
largely sort of farmland open land
undeveloped to the south-west and partly
the northern boundary there is an
existing residential property close by
under the same ownership and then
there's a potash garden center to the
east and some existing residential
properties along main road if we can
take you to the existing plans please
the proposal is for the conversion of
the four existing poultry sheds so
they're thought floor plans they're only
very small changes proposed to the
external appearance of these units so
this is the what was should have said
they exist what it shows existing
pattern of fenestration so doors and
openings to the building and if I take
you to the proposed plans what you'll
see is that they're very similar but
what your what they want on the frontage
is roller shutter doors to each of the
four units the facing material is also
proposed to be updated you'll see some
photos shortly as the proposed changes
to the building are minimal parking what
we've provided to if we can take you to
the location plan to one side of one of
the buildings and then a couple of
spaces here there's an existing in and
out access to the site frontage and this
is all hard-surfaced that there's no
change proposed in relation to that the
council's development plan allows for
the conversion of existing buildings in
the Greenbelt subject to policy DM 13
and it's set out in the report the
requirements of this pala
see the existing building is a permanent
and substantial construction which is
the first prerequisite of this policy
the building would not be extended at
all if I can take you to the photos just
briefly just scroll down please sorry
the first 2i they're all in one document
I couldn't change that if you can just
scroll down so this is the access from
Main Roads
that's an existing point of access to
the highway if you could to scroll down
us again please until you find an image
of the the proposed the changes that
have happened to the building you'll see
the change in the facing material so
there you go
so as during the course of the
application having been submitted when
the officer dealing with the application
visited the site it was noted that some
of the proposed work had taken place and
it's understood that the site now is
occupied by a b8 user the second
requirement relating to the Greenbelt is
that it would not have any the proposed
use would not have any greater impact in
terms of vehicle movements associated
with it obviously there were vehicle
movements associated with this site in
relation to the poultry use and the
officer recommendation states that this
used the b8 storage and distribution use
would have no greater impact on the
character or appearance of the Greenbelt
the application therefore chairman is
for approval subject to the recommended
conditions no neighbour objections have
been received and there is no objection
from the county highway officer thank
you
1 presentation mr. Jennings Thank You
chairman and I'm Kate Jennings from well
as you're not representing the applicant
Rankin farms limited as the planning
officer has covered quite concisely the
proposal is policy compliance for the
reuse of an existing rural building
within the Greenbelt until the site was
recently sold by the poultry company it
was operated as a poultry rearing site
which had traffic noise and smells
associated with it the proposed use is a
story juice at the time of the
application that at the time the
application was submitted the site was
not in use however since that time the
landowner has secured interest from a
suitable tenant and took to start repair
replacing some of the
as shown in the photographs and at least
has been secured the company is a
logistics company that's using the site
as a storage facility deliveries will be
made to and from the site but the site
is for storage only there is no retail
wholesale and the current conditions
proposed by the planners ensure that
this is the case the level of traffic is
not significantly different from the
previous agricultural activity at this
site and as such the adjacent highway
would not be detrimental II affected I
think it's quite underestimated the
amount of movements to and from poultry
sheds with feed and clearing Birds in
and out of the shed so there was a high
level of movement in and out of this
site the fact that the company have sold
and moved out there has been a quiet
period it is noted that highways have
not objected to this proposal the
proposed hours of operation are accepted
by the applicant and landscaping can be
provided as agreed with the council
the proposal is supported by both
national and local planning policy and
as received no objections from local
residents all statutory consultation to
support the officers recommendation for
approval very much summation as you've
waited so patiently whereas you've
referred the item and you just put your
microphone on that place and thank you
mr. chairman members of the committee I
was concerned about this application
which is why I've referred it there are
three main areas of concern in the
offices of regional report
work on altering a altering the premises
had already begun and on the 20th it was
confirmed that the company was already
operating from this site therefore this
is now a retrospective application with
the applicant now operating from the
premises
despite being aware that the Development
Committee were determining this tonight
I was surprised to hear the office of
presenting saying that there were no
objections for Essex highways because as
late as Monday the officer told me that
they had had no communication from
six highways despite asking for
information from them prior to December
so I'm not sure what the situation is
there but they had the officer advised
that they had not responded at the
highway assessment of the b101 three
during the last allocation of sites when
the Christmas tree farm estate was
developed the road was deemed to be at
about 80 percent which was described as
almost a capacity capacity is less than
100 percent which of course we would
assume the information regarding the
anticipated amount of traffic is varied
but the latest information available has
been to activate lorries per day three
vans the number of visits not specified
in tents staff the staff members alone
could create 40 car movements a day one
of the justifications for this is that
the vehicle movements would be no more
than the existing use however as we have
heard the buildings have been redundant
for some time so there is in fact no
existing use and that would mean that
the proposal is not satisfied 10 - in
the offices report and since the times
when the poultry sheds were there that
the cap at the volume of traffic has
increased on the b101 3 however we I
don't know the situation because I
wasn't aware that Essex I always had
responded the main concern regarding
this application is a change of use from
green belt to b8 a wide-ranging class
that covers storage and distribution
including wholesale warehousing
distribution centers and repositories
examples of b8 use could be a
supermarket distribution center or
individual storage units for the public
and could create an acceptable following
a traffic movement therefore should the
committee decide to grant this
application I would trust that
conditions to prevent excessive use in
this area imposed the previous proposal
for a grain store was refused and the
appeal dismissed in my view this is a
much more commercial and inappropriate
use of this site
with the potential for uncontrollable
intensification the site lies partly
within the Roche Valley special
landscape area and is in the green belt
and no very special circumstances to
deviate from the RDCs policy and as
stated before this does not satisfy all
the criteria in Section ten at the
officer and I have researched on Google
and we have found that the other
industrial at their other industrial
locations and all there are locations
are in dust on earth that we could find
were on industrial sites the company
operates 8:30 to 5:30 yet they are
requesting much longer hours of
operation in this rural location my main
concern remains about the
appropriateness of this use in this
location I would ask the committee to
consider carefully whether or not this
application should be approved should
the committee decide to approve this
application I would suggest the
following conditions no public or
wholesale from the site and that is in
line with an agreement and information
provided by the applicant that the use
hereby permitted should not take place
and no delivery should be taken act or
dispatched from the site outside the
hours of 8:00 it's a 6 p.m. Monday to
Friday in line with the application but
not permitted on Saturdays or Sundays no
plant machinery should be operated
before 8 a.m. or after 6 p.m.
unfortunately just by asking we don't
know what the nature of the business is
so the conditions are suggesting have to
cover a wide remit and also for possible
future b8 use no external lighting
should be installed and or operated in
any part of the site unless details have
been submitted to and approved in
writing by the local authority and the
external area must not be used for any
other purpose other than staff
and visitor parking no goods articles
products or other materials together
with plant machinery or equipment
whether or not with quiz it for the use
of the sites should be stored or deposit
externally so I leave it up to the
members to decide whether this is an
appropriate use and whether they feel
that by adding on a few conditions that
the use would be acceptable in that area
thank you Thank You chairman
I go to disagree somewhat with the
previous speaker the use of these
buildings yes I'll agree haven't been in
use for some time but I think there are
schemes there are encouragement from
central government to look at bringing
disused farm buildings in particular
back into use so I'm quite happy to
encourage that I don't have any
particular concerns around vehicle
movements I don't anticipate it being
40-ton Arctic's coming in and out there
because the sheer movement it is a farm
road where tractors and things have for
many years have been used okay haven't
been much for the last few years but
there's nothing to stop that from
happening
couple of concerns I do have though one
is with the doors that are being
installed with regards to noise roller
shutters aren't the quietest door to
open and close so I'd like some some
sort of clarification under on how
they're being got to be operated with
regards to the hours I don't have a
problem between Monday to Friday 8:00 to
6:00 don't have a problem with that and
I don't have a problem with no use on
Sundays and bank holidays but I do think
we should though the committee should
allow some use on a Saturday maybe just
a two to one or something along
I think it would be unreasonable for
this committee to impose no no use at
all on a Saturday I think that's about
all I have to say Jeff thank you okay
cancer Stanley you indicated Thank You
chairman
for obvious reasons that there are four
large area buildings that may be used by
separate other ships and yes I can see
that there could be quite quite
considerable traffic in their area
however I agree with what's been said
already as a eight to six I'd like to
see and also eight to twelve on a
Saturday with Sunday's and bank holidays
exploded the other thing that really
worries me a little bit is the fact that
have we put any condition on for
retail usage of these premises I don't
know if we have perhaps the officer
could let me know but as for the
shutters they are they're quite silent
they're plastic coated they're very I
mean you wouldn't even hear them go up
all day and these days especially if
they're motorised they are really really
quiet so I shouldn't have any problems
with the shutters these are new new hero
on doors and closures that we have and
they are really really quiet
so I don't see any problem with those at
all that is my only okay so thank you
thank you thanks Jamie
so certainly think that must agree with
further comments by mrs. counselor mrs.
Mason I am concerned about what could
possibly be stored in in this size and
can we impose a condition that no
dangerous materials would be stored
there
why not that that's a separate such as
legislation this is planning permission
but surely as you start planning now
it's a licensing thing I am concerned
about the traffic as well the display
gusset home lane onto the b101 3 is very
small you try and get an artic turning
in it especially out of that turning I
wouldn't be surprised if the wheels of
the trailer possibly could end up in the
ditch thank you sorry I think members we
do have to be particularly aware of the
previous use might not happen for a
couple of years but it can start again
tomorrow with the previous level of
heavy vehicle movements and so on I
agree with it counts receptor one who's
speaking about us supporting business I
would be happy to perhaps for the
limitation on wholesale and public use
because this is a commercial promote
premises I think if you're if you're
talking about distribution it's probably
possibly unfair on a business to put
restrictions over the weekend and I
don't have the level of concern that
perhaps what some other members have
expressed about such as in Sunday's
based on the fact that there has been
notification to the usual parties and
there haven't been any objections at all
from any other parties so I'd be happy
to accept the officers recommendation
just with one more condition regarding
the MU removal of wholesale and public
trading
I think we could incorporate the
restriction in relation to no public
wholesale retail at all from the site at
any time in relation to condition three
so you could expand that just for
clarification so condition three already
restricts the use solely to use within
the b8 use class but we can add in
that's other element members I don't
know it so it's fairly straightforward
one here so I'll move to Stanley can we
still maintain the where we've put in no
operation on the sunday and bank
holidays well I think in relation to any
condition we need to understand the
reason for it and then this is the
concern about the time limits relating
to impact on residential because
actually the residential is quite quite
a distance from the site and those
existing properties haven't have a road
outside the main road outside those
properties anyway so I think we just
need to unpick a bit more if we are
going to change the timings what the
reason for that it particularly given
that the putting a further restriction
is going to affect the the business
that's seeking to occupy and be aware of
other businesses operating with
significantly higher levels of trade
immediately adjacent to the site as well
cancer Stanley then I'm just going to
heavy goods vehicles and not to cars
where other businesses are working on
Saturdays Sundays I'm I'm just a
considering that heavy goods vehicles
will actually make a heavy heavy goods
vehicle to go down that road at any time
there are no residential properties
adjacent to this site I just don't see
that as sustainable
well members are moving from the chair
the recommendation as its printed with
the addition of the expansion of item
three regarding wholesale public they
are the item for approval is printed on
eight point one point five going on to
eight point one point six those members
are in favor of the approval please
indicate those against two three that
item is carried thank you very much for
your attendance meeting closed